[Music]
my name is kylie eckert
and the disease i chose is autosomal
dominant polycystic kidney disease
also known as pkd or polycystic kidney
disease
what is pkd pkd is caused by a mutation
in the pkd1 gene
although in more rare circumstances it
can be caused by
mutations in the pkd2 gene
and or um mutations in the protein
polycystin mutations in the pkd1 gene
cause
growth of cysts on the kidneys leading
to kidney failure in
approximately the fifth decade of life
however it affects
it can affect people between the ages of
0 and 80.
it is the most common common monogenic
kidney disease
and it affects over 12 million people
worldwide
the primary unit pro accession number is
displayed on the screen
there were two other uniproduct session
numbers however
they did not have any relevant
information to this presentation
the information from the primary
uniprice entry is reliable because it
was manually reviewed by swiss prop
it has a 5 out of 5 annotation score and
it has experimental evidence at the
protein level
pkd1 is located on human chromosome 16.
the only disease that pkd1 is implicated
in is autosomal dominant polycystic
kidney disease and the honor id of pkd
is number one seven three
nine zero zero
the pdb id for pkd
is 1b4r 1b4r
is actually the number for polycystin
one which is the protein
produced by the pkd1 gene
because there was only one reviewed
entry
in uniprot for pkd1 genes
i blasted all sequences that had greater
than 90
identity so that i would at least have
some results and a phylogenetic tree
these are diagrams the one on the left
is the human
poly pkd1 pkd2 complex and the one on
the right
is the human polycystin one complex
polycystin one is the protein produced
by the gene
pkd1
also there are no ligand interactions
for this complex
on scop i found the family super family
fold and class these this is all
class information for polycystin one
the protein they're all beta proteins
and just folded in an immunoglobulin
globulin like beta sandwich
in pymol i was unable to
pull up and fetch one b4r
which is polycysteine one so i modeled
pkd1 pkd2
the top picture is the complete
structure of the complex
the middle is zoomed in to show where
the mutation is which is right here
and the bottom picture is a magnified
picture of the
mutated amino ac the mutation that i
chose
is in position 3285
it causes polycystic kidney disease and
it's a change from
valene to isoleucine i
found this mutation by comparing a list
of pathological and disease implicated
mutations
in uniprot to the available mutations
in the mutation wizard in pymol
for the electrostatic model i was unable
to find an electrostatic
um structure online and in pymol for the
pkd1 pk22 complex
the error message that i found is on the
left here
but i was able to find an electrostatic
model of the 1v4r
or polycysteine 1 complex
finally these are my works cited thank
you